bonjour à toutes et à tous aujourd'hui
un épisode un peu spécial
je vous emmène voir jupiter non pas ceux
jupiter la la planète jupiter une des
planètes du système solaire les plus
étudiés et je trouve la plus fascinante
[Musique]
ce type d'image est obtenu par les
sondes spatiales comme juno qui orbite
autour de jupiter pour la photographier
mesurer son champ magnétique sont sans
gravité ou encore sa température
mais malheureusement les conditions
extrêmes de température et de pression
empêche d'étudier directement
l'intérieur de jupiter alors pour
comprendre ce qu'il se passe dans et
sous ses gros nuages
certains chercheurs ont choisi de regret
la planète géante en laboratoire ise
cette fois on a choisi de quitter le
confort du studio zeste de sciences pour
vous emmener voir ça à marseille
voilà c'est rapide à ces foulées
transport de nos jours bienvenue à lire
fait l'institut de recherche sur le
phénomène hors équilibre et ici il y à
un canal hydraulique une soufflerie et
des oliviers et ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui la mécanique des fluides en
rotation sur les planètes
bonjour daphné bonjour les as tu as une
magnifique manip
alors en effet ici on a une toute
nouvelle installation expérimentale où
on a pris une grosse cuve cylindrique en
plexiglas et on l'a remplie avec 800
litres d'eau est en fait cette cuve
remplie d'eau va la mettre en rotation
très rapide donc ce qui nous intéresse
c'est de décrire les mouvements
d'ensemble qu'on va observer et de
comparer tout ça avec ce qui se passe
sur jupiter et notamment tous les
mouvements atmosphériques qu'on voit les
bandes les vortex sur jupiter
on va chercher à observer les mouvements
du fluide et cette caméra va observer
tout ce qui se passe sur un plan
d'affaires on va créer avec ce laser ici
sur le côté là haut c'est comme si on
regardait depuis le pôle de jupiter les
mouvements dans son axe et sert
exactement c'est une vue du pôle de
jupiter qu'on reproduit en laboratoire
[Musique]
jupiter est une planète géante etc la
peluche géante des géantes c'est à dire
qu'elle est plus grosse et plus lourde
que toutes les autres planètes de notre
système solaire
bref la tâche rouge là elle fait à peu
près la taille de la terre et on
pourrait faire rentrer plus de 1300 fois
notre planète dans le volume de jupiter
mais jupiter est une géante gazeuse est
ce que l'on voit ce n'est pas une
surface solide
d'ailleurs elle n'en a peut-être pas du
tout même sous les nuages
elle est constituée majoritairement
d'hydrogène qui passe progressivement de
la forme gazeuse à la forme liquide
plus on se rapproche du centre de la
planète cool et ben du coup on va faire
tourner ça à londres
[Musique]
ok donc là on est prêtes à faire la
manie en effet là tu vois qu'on a mis la
table en rotation à 40 tours par minute
plage et en direct ce que voit la caméra
du dessus et on va éteindre la lumière
pour voir ce qu'on voit dans le noir
donc là ce que je fais c'est que
j'active les pompes qui sont à la base
de la cub
ouais et tout ça ça va mettre en
mouvement les particules et on va les
voir apparaître sur le plan laser et
donc sur la caméra donc là tu confonds
le jacuzzi
exactement je vais allumer le jacuzzi
[Musique]
à ce moment là vous vous demandez
sûrement comment est ce qu'on peut voir
les mouvements de l'eau alors que c'est
un film transparent
l'astuce dans la manif de l'équipe de
daphné c'est d'ajouter dans l'eau des
petites billes et réfléchissante et
d'éclairer avec un laser l'eau entraîne
les particules et la caméra enregistre
leur mouvement d'ailleurs c'est une
méthode très utilisé en mécanique des
fluides pour suivre l'évolution des
écoulements et ça s'appelle pays a heavy
vélocimétrie par image de particules
donc là on voit les tournions comment
est ce qu'on peut faire l'analogie avec
une planète sont modélisés dans cette
expérience par rapport à jupiter ce
serait vraiment une fraction de jupiter
concentré près du pôle que tu serais pas
très profond ce serait quelques milliers
de kilomètres depuis la seconde appelée
la surface de jupiter
pourquoi on se permet de faire cette
analogie c'est vraiment parce qu'on a
injecté dans notre expérience les
ingrédients fondamentaux pour comprendre
la dynamique de sutter par exemple la
rotation de la planète et on a recréé
tous les systèmes de petits tourbillons
de petites tempêtes qu'on peut observer
dans l'atmosphère de hockey revenons un
instant sur jupiter
elle tourne très rapidement sur
elle-même une journée sur jupiter c'est
seulement 9 heures et on appelle ça un
jour jean bien un jour jean bien un jour
j'en reviens pas les bandes que vous
voyez ici sont des courants de vents
très violents
plus de 500 kilomètres heure qui souffle
dans des sens opposés
on appelle aussi ces courants dg jovien
[Musique]
demain encore ne sortait pas vos
parapluies sous les tropiques
car les vents d'est pourront atteindre
600 kilomètres heure alors qu aux
latitudes plus élevées
les vents d'ouest souffleront à plus de
500 kilomètres heure comme tous les
jours depuis
et bien depuis des siècles bon on va pas
faire ça tous les jours c'est toujours
pareil non ce que les chercheurs
essayent de comprendre grâce à leurs
manifs c'est quels sont les ingrédients
nécessaires à la formation des bandes de
jupiter à quelle profondeur ces bandes
descente dans la planète et est ce que
leur forme leur position leur sens reste
constant au cours du temps
[Musique]
donc là tu vois que sous l'effet de la
rotation bas la surface de l'eau est
devenue complètement paraboliques ça
fait comme quand on touche à café en
face à sastre up
voilà ça a causé la surface de l'eau
sûrs aucun petite échelle on va des
tourbillons et à grande échelle ce cessé
de suivre globalement le flic voix qui
va dans ce sens là alors que si rien de
plus à l'intérieur de la cub la situe le
suit globalement tu vas qui remonte dans
l'autre sens là
c'est une ces particules elle va dans le
sens on va enregistrer ce moment là
pendant plusieurs heures dans l'idéal et
ensuite on va analyser toutes ces
données pour voir quels sont les
mouvements préférentiel suivi par les
particules et voir si on arrive à
reconstituer la formation de bande
et puis on peut même analyse et attend
pour tous les phénomènes qui conduisent
à la formation ses bandas alors
concrètement on fait comment pour
traiter ces données
eh bien on part des images de la caméra
qui filme le dessus de la cuve
et ces images permettent d'obtenir le
déplacement des particules et donc la
vitesse du fluide qui les entraîne en
faisant la moyenne de tous ses
déplacements
on arrive à une image comme celle ci et
daphné va nous en dire plus
on a représenté ici le sens de
l'écoulement en rouge on a représenté le
fluide lorsqu'ils se déplacent dans le
même sens que la rotation de la table et
en bleu lorsqu'il se déplace dans un
sens opposé à la rotation la table et
donc tu peux voir ici qu'on a une
formation de bande qui est donc analogue
à ce qu'on observe sur jupiter
quand on la regarde vue du pôle d'accord
et là au milieu et donc au milieu on a
une simulation numérique de la manip qui
a été effectué par benjamin
donc ça c'est une image qui vient d'une
simulation numérique donc dans les mêmes
conditions que l'expérience pour voir
comment le flux de structure et on voit
bien qu'on reproduit la structure en
bande de l'expérience du coup là c'est
quelque chose qui est en 3d c'est une
coupe à travers un domaine qui est 3d
donc là on voit ici vu du dessus le
cylindre qu'on a coupé en deux donc si
on se déplace à un terreau de la manne
est donc on voit bien la structure
tridimensionnelle de l'écoulement on
voit bien que les jets convoi en surface
pénètre très profondément à l'intérieur
de la cuve
du coup c'est quoi l'intérêt d'avoir une
modélisation et une expérience c'est
toujours assez complémentaires puisque
donc l'expérience on est limité dans les
quantités d'informations qu'on peut
extraire on a vu le plan laser donc on a
juste de l'information au niveau du plan
laser la simulation on a une information
complètement 3d de tout le système ça me
permet de vérifier de comparer ce qui se
passe dans la manip et dans la
simulation pour la question de la
longévité la stabilité dgeq et qu'est ce
qui nous intéresse nous sur eux sur
jupiter le numérique n'est pas très
adapté ce qu'on peut juste faire
quelques dizaines voire centaines de
temps de rotation mais c'est tout alors
que la manip va la faire tourner pendant
des heures ce qui correspond à un très
très grand nombre de votants notation
sur jupiter pourquoi c'est intéressant
d'étudier la longévité de ses membres
alors la logistique zélande c'est que
c'est on observe depuis des centaines
d'années c'est quelque chose qui est
très surprenant parce qu'on s'attendrait
à ce que les j'ai évolué dynamique nom
change au cours du temps et alors que ça
fait 400 ans quand les observent quelque
chose qui n'est pas bien compris et
c'est quoi du coup le futur pour 7 pour
cette manip
alors pour cette manif la terne
bien suivre au fur et à mesure tous les
résultats que va nous amener la mission
juno est donc maintenant on a un super
outil pour essayer d'étudier tous les
phénomènes qu'on observe sur jupiter par
exemple ya des vortex ont été observés
au pôle de jupiter récemment on pourrait
essayer de les reproduire dans notre
manie ok bah merci beaucoup merci de
m'avoir accueilli dans ce dans ce labo
avec cette magnifique expérience et
pourquoi
voilà j'espère que vous avez aimé ce
nouveau format nous ça nous a bien plu
de travailler dessus donc donnez nous
votre avis faites nous des retours et
puis dites nous si vous en voulez plus
éphéméride demain la journée ne durera
que neuf heures et nous fêterons les
jovial bonne fête à toutes les jeux
vianne ne nous mettez pas en avant
abonnez vous nom de zeus